[Music]
hey you guys it's sunday yeah i totally
forgot that it was uh spring forward
that it was uh yeah
yeah daylight savings time yeah it was
like i woke up and i was like wow i over
slept until
like 8 30 which is like really really
late for me because usually i wake up
like before seven but then i came in my
office like after a few minutes and i
was like why is it 10 o'clock already
i'm like that's not funny
and then i was like oh
spring forward so you know
i got up did laundry ran down the biker
bar was there all day yeah you've been
at the biker bar all day you know what's
really funny i was like sitting here
and i was like holy [ __ ] like i did uh a
bunch of [ __ ] today and uh you know oh
okay okay and uh did some videos made
some videos and edited them and stuff
and then i'm like oh my god we have to
do the show at five i'm like did he
forget like what time it was because we
went forward on the thing although his
tablet should have updated automatically
and then it's like ten till and i'm like
um is he not coming back or whatever and
then like um
i had just got the new ethernet cable
because remember we had we got the
ethernet cable before
and we hooked it up and it worked really
good like on friday night's show but
that ethernet cable was only 50 feet
long
so
like right after that show i ordered 100
foot one and it came like 15 minutes
before the show started yeah so we had
so i had to like unroll it and like take
it like all the way down i hooked it up
that's what we're on now it seems to be
working good yeah yeah i was down to
[ __ ] down at the biker bar hanging
out with those dudes and uh taking
videos
and uh i was getting into it i'll tell
you that if i could post one of them and
dj maniac he's online right now he goes
dude man you need to get back you gotta
[ __ ] live stream and i was like oh
yeah i guess i did yeah so i shut it
down right then [ __ ] mate and then
came back see we've even got like
like fans out there is like uh tom get
your dumbbell phone please no i was just
oh i got a half hour i'll be fine i kept
because i'm sitting up here going yeah
you're gonna have to be he's in such big
[ __ ] trouble yeah cause i didn't
think he was going to get back in time
because it's like it was like quarter
till and i'm using like 10 till or
something i'm like come on what the [ __ ]
i'm not doing this by myself yeah
yeah that's getting all kinds of tension
up there so it's looking that it's time
tom needs attention all that time
attention and [ __ ] for everybody buying
me drinks and everything so
just how how many how many drinks did
you get bought for you uh three two or
three of them yeah that's nice
two or three of them and i i paid for
four myself
i walked out of there [ __ ] 20 bucks
20 bucks that's what it cost me oh okay
that's not bad no that's not bad that's
not bad that's not bad no i'm trying to
think well no they were they were uneasy
on me they're like here here here
i guess i'm entertaining everybody
i i spent 30 30 at dollar general yeah
if that's if that's any consolation yeah
yeah
some more cookies
no okay
i got i got cat treats i got some makeup
i was out of i got um
i got some can't i got some coffee
drinks in a can because they had them
like three for five dollars or something
they're uh
and then i got some coffee creamer
and like a couple other things i don't
remember just like stupid little [ __ ] um
yeah so we're gonna talk about beverly
hills cop right right yeah great movie
we watched it again we watched it friday
night after the show
so i was a little bit drunk but i mean
i'd seen it before i've seen it like a
million times
uh so so i remember the [ __ ] that
happens in it and honestly okay here's
something that i didn't know i mean
there's all kind of fascinating facts
about this [ __ ] movie
but one of them that i didn't know was
that the director of it martin brest who
i would probably change my name
but you know
um yeah so he got he directed this he
wasn't the first choice i think they
wanted martin scorsese to do it which
would have been a whole different uh
ball game
but he actually this was a massive
success obviously he went on and did
midnight run which was i think that was
robert de niro right and like so that
then scent of a woman with al pacino
meet joe black
and then after that he did that [ __ ]
movie
geely
that one with benefir like ben affleck
and jennifer lopez the one that everyone
said was like the worst abomination
i haven't seen it either i kind of want
to watch it just out of curiosity
because it got [ __ ] on so hard but like
pretty much it's one of those like
infamous bad movies like
showgirls or
uh ishtar or something like that
and i don't know i don't i don't know if
i want to see it or not because but it
was one of those movies and i didn't
realize that that was the same guy that
had directed beverly hills did he do
beverly hills cop too
um i don't know well that might have
been a different cause i think we're
gonna we should wat we're gonna watch
tonight and then talk about that
tomorrow and maybe do the third one so
we might do the whole trilogy because
i'll tell you one thing beverly hills
cop this movie is a great movie
it's fun it's a low budget movie but
it's just a great movie um there's
something about the dialogue eddie
murphy the music
the edit
it's a low budget movie but it's
punching way above its weight i i always
i love this movie from the time it came
out
and there's so many memorable lines from
this movie
um
is it perfect no it's a low-budget movie
it's just a good movie
yeah i think this only costs what like
15 million or yeah which that's 20
million or something like that and i
have to say too that
this was actually
the highest grossing
movie
um of 1984 at least like in north
america as far as i know
and think of all the other [ __ ] that
came out in 1984 ghostbusters
yeah gremlins the terminator yeah and
this beat all of them yeah this made
like 234 million [ __ ] dollars yep
and yeah i mean this was like a massive
now eddie murphy had been in a couple
movies prior to this i think he was only
23 when he made this movie it's
ridiculous he had done he did trading
places before this right i think in 48
hours maybe yeah um
so he was like a big star but he doesn't
come off as that young though he does
yeah he doesn't i was actually surprised
when i finally comes off as a guy in his
30s
but now he's really young but it's just
a great detective movie
even though he's a cop but he's doing it
you know what i mean he's still on the
force he's just doing this [ __ ] on his
own and it solidified this axel foley
character in my mind and i was just like
i just think he's a [ __ ] great
character
now
beverly hills cop 2 i i remembered it
being better we're gonna see it tonight
i remembered it i remember that being
actually better than this one i mean i'm
sure i've seen i've seen all of them at
one point or another but honestly this
one is kind of the only one that sticks
in my mind yeah um so i'm kind of i'm
looking forward to seeing the second one
i remember i remember two being better
and i don't know it'd be hard to be
better than this one though all right
well we'll see but i remember getting
better and then i remember uh three
being oh no not as good as as onerous i
kind of feel like that's the
overwhelming opinion that people were
like oh the first two are great and then
the third one
well you know by the time you're getting
to the third one everybody's just kind
of like no thanks but one of the reasons
why we're revisiting this one and i
haven't told i don't know if i told
jenny this but
the reason why i wanted to revisit it
because i have heard that the next eddie
murphy to come movie to come out
is gonna be
an axo foley movie they have been
talking about it for a really long time
yeah now they came out with [ __ ]
coming to america too it was it was a
great movie it was good great pg movie
you know
uh i think that was a netflix only
wasn't it when that came out was it yeah
that's an it's a netflix original right
exactly
yeah
so um i don't know if that's going to be
the case with uh with beverly hills cop
four
but i have a good feeling that
the next beverly hills cop move that
comes out will be a hit it'll be very
good i mean if they do a good job on it
i don't see why it wouldn't be i mean
like i said coming to america too was
all right but you know dolomite is my
name was pretty [ __ ] fantastic yeah
so that's i don't know
alone i kind of feel like
like yeah if they did beverly hills
company because look at all of the all
of the stuff that they're doing now uh
you know with like reboots and stuff
like that from the 80s i feel like
there's like a really big audience out
there for that do you know what's really
interesting i didn't know this
prior to like researching this movie but
back in i think it was
2013 i want to say
they actually were gonna do a tv series
based on beverly hills cop they made a
pilot it was gonna be i think eddie
murphy was gonna be in it but it was
mostly gonna be the main character's
gonna be like his son who is also a cop
and uh so they made the pilot and
you know judge reinhold was gonna be in
it and like so they had some people from
the original movie but apparently like
it didn't get uh picked up so they just
kind of like abandoned it they're in
there going banana that's right banana
tailpipe
there's so many [ __ ] lines from this
movie that are iconic
even jenny was like oh my brother used
to say that we there's just a lot of
[ __ ] when you were kids and they played
this over and over again on [ __ ]
cable
and me and mike kowalski grant there's
no serious me and mike cole also would
watch this [ __ ] on vhs [ __ ] just over
and over again we just [ __ ] loved it
this one and the second one
and there was just
scenes in it that would stick in your
head you know
you had to be there at the time it
wouldn't happen today because the social
media just [ __ ]
overwhelms everything just with the
sheer volume of data
but in the 80s you know what i mean you
were limited in what you could see and
what you could get your hands on and
this [ __ ] here was just this is just a
great movie and um i was what we watched
it last uh what was it last night the
night before it was friday night friday
and uh we i watched it and it was just
like this this holds up
i'm pretty sure it totally this holds up
it's a good movie
yeah
and it
it's a good just a good detective movie
is it accurate
no
no it's not we got grandpa's in the at
and we got grafters in the [ __ ] in
the in the audience he's a professional
policeman from this area
our ex-cop
you couldn't do the [ __ ] axel did and
got away with it they would [ __ ] fire
your ass but that was kind of like
that's like a trope of like action
movies and comedies especially in the
80s where you know the guy that doesn't
play by the rules but he gets the job
done so he gets away with it even though
he's always in trouble that's kind of
like that yeah that's like now weird
thing about this movie is that this
movie was gonna be a sylvester stallone
movie yeah he but sly said well i want
this change i want my name to be this
and this and that coop ready yeah i want
my name to be really pretty i want i
want this to happen anyway nah then this
one isn't for you but another dude heard
that he goes no i'll make that movie
with you i'll make that movie and it
split into two it became
cobra cobra cobra
so cobra was the [ __ ]
cobra was like kind of like the
offspring of this movie but originally
it was gonna be um a [ __ ] sylvester
stallone flick
yeah like dark and gritty yeah and
honestly you know what's crazy to me
like you know this many years later
considering how iconic this movie is
eddie murphy was absolutely not the
first choice for this uh you know who
the first choice was mickey rourke oh
god this movie would have been forgotten
and mickey rourke i love mickey rourke
yeah
yeah i don't think that he was the right
well because when they were first like
you know throwing this around like i
said martin score says he was going to
be the director on it so they were kind
of
at first got it kind of going into more
like gritty action movie direction but
then as it evolved it started they
started like lightening it up more so it
was more like a comedy
um but even then i kind of feel like uh
who the [ __ ] else there was like a bunch
of other actors that they asked to be in
it there were some of them were comedic
actors but most of them were like kind
of serious
and i just don't know how that would
have worked out but that's [ __ ] funny
about sylvester stallone yeah so they
asked him to be in it and he's like well
you know he's a writer too uh obviously
and he's so he's like
yeah and he's like oh i want to rewrite
it
so he rewrote it to be like super super
dark and gritty yeah so much so that
they compared like his opening scene in
it to
like the normandy station like it was
gonna be this big [ __ ] uh this big
[ __ ] violent whatever yeah and uh
yeah so they were just kind of like no
we're gonna we're gonna be funny instead
yeah so yeah there was that but i do
it's just weird how it evolved over the
years and i think didn't they do a
movies that made us about this i kind of
feel like you know that netflix series
yeah i think maybe they did did they
because i kind of i really do feel like
maybe it sounds familiar
it was at least mentioned in it yeah the
the the thing is is that
stallone actually had good ideas but it
was far outside the scope of what
beverly hills cop yeah is
he was talking about cobra and somebody
said yeah yeah we'll do that and then
they made the movie cobra and i i've
seen that recently about a year or two
back and cobra actually kind of holds up
i remember it's actually better than i
remembered
i'd have to watch it again i remember
not liking it when i saw it first time
when i first saw it i didn't like it i
saw it again and i was like no this is
actually pretty good um
it's funny because they actually made a
joke about that in part in beverly hills
cop2 where i think there's actually a
poster of cobra yeah in there in the
background and i think what's her face
is in
in it too that was in cobra what's her
name bridget nielsen reginald yeah i
think she like turned up about she's
like that's kind of like a joke yeah
she's in both movies that's what i'm
saying part two yeah so that's why
they're they were like kind of making a
joke about that
um [ __ ] cobra i didn't like it the
first time i saw it but on repeated
viewings so now it's pretty good
is it as good as beverly hills cop
no [ __ ] no no bear those cops better i
mean very few movies are as good as
beverly hills yeah you want you wanna
you know what's interesting i see
because i'm always interested
especially movies that came out in the
80s like when i was growing up that i
saw when i was younger
and a lot of times you know stuff that
you saw some of them you see them later
and you're like oh my god that sucks so
bad it's like you just like it because
of nostalgia so i'm always kind of
interested people that weren't even
[ __ ] born when this [ __ ] came out and
then they see it
the for the first time like recently and
i'm always kind of interested how they
see it so i saw this one reviewer
who
he's not that young he said he was born
in 1988
but he had never seen this movie
and he watched it last year and he just
thought he said he was a fan of eddie
murphy's like old stand-up
so he had seen that but he had never
really seen he had never seen this movie
and he just thought this was like one of
the funniest things that he'd ever seen
so i guess like the the humor does still
hold up for like younger people seeing
it now for the first time even though
you don't have the context well the
world holds up yeah that this is in this
is happening in the 80s
in detroit and in
beverly hills
and it's a fish out of water story about
a cop who went rogue to become a private
investigator
to solve the murder of one of his
hoodlum friends
and he has to go to
he has to go to beverly hills to do it
where does it [ __ ] it's especially in
those days
[ __ ] polar opposites
detroit was [ __ ] broke it was [ __ ]
broke
even grampus is not saying that if you
were a detroit cop back in those days
you didn't have any goddamn money they
didn't paid peanuts yeah he goes to
beverly hills the [ __ ] richest
neighborhood in the united states at
that time
to solve a murder he's a total fish out
of water he's in his old [ __ ] jalopy
his little [ __ ] beetle i love that
there's [ __ ]
and he's trying to survive around these
cops and he's
according to his job and toward
according to his boss
his boss in this movie grandpa's
mentioned this too yeah a couple people
mentioned i believe he really was the
chief of police yeah or he was a cop at
least
i think he was the chief of police at
that time
plays the chief of police of the detroit
police department in the movie it uh it
is actually him
i think he was the chief of the police
that's the way i remembered it he did
the he he did a cameo role as himself
like yelling at you yelling at actual
following
chief will tell you what no you got some
ass left i can see you walked away you
got some ass left
for some reason that that line always
makes me laugh
let's do it that always babies you still
got some ass left yeah
don't [ __ ] be foley
well the awesome thing about this is
like i mean eddie murphy improved a lot
of that you know the one scene where
he's talking about like um the two cops
like [ __ ] judge reinhold and the
other guy and he's saying it's like you
know these these aren't even just cop
they're super cops all they're doing the
capes and then that was all uh
that was all improved um i was watching
something earlier i think it's minty
comedic arts he's this australian guy
and he does like all these fun facts
about different movies and he loves 80s
movies so he was talking about this one
and he said that eddie murphy at this
time that he was getting like really
tired because they'd done so many takes
and they were like well can we give you
something to like pep you up and he's
like look i don't want any he didn't
want any coffee because he's like i
don't want any drugs or anything of that
kind but they're like come on just you
know please so they kept giving him like
little bits of coffee so he would get
all like [ __ ] parked up and i guess
because he didn't drink coffee at that
time i guess it affected him a lot more
than it would normally so they said yeah
he was all hopped up on caffeine during
that scene but yeah he did improv a lot
of [ __ ]
and
a lot of the [ __ ] that he improved you
know are some of the best lines in the
movie i wonder if the whole like you
still have some ass left lying because
that's one of my favorites
well i i talked about this on one of our
earlier shows and i mentioned daddy
eddie murphy
for y'all who are too young to remember
almost i am too young to remember this
okay because a lot of this was going on
when i was a little kid
saturday night live was almost getting
ready to get canceled all the good
talent like john belushi and i was gonna
had died or left the show
and
saturday live was gonna die
eddie murphy basically single-handedly
saved saved the saturday night live back
in the 80s
uh he had a really good energy he was
real [ __ ] funny
and on the back of some of the improv
skits that he would come up with
saturday live was able to kind of
recruit more talent because eddie was
there yeah you know
he uh but without eddie snl would have
been under long time ago
you know long time ago so he kind of
saved that
uh
snl is not funny anymore it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but well i don't think it's i haven't
watched it so i can't really say but i
kind of feel like it wasn't funny even
when
yeah like even back in the evening
even in the 90s it wasn't fun
uh but it had its moments but yeah eddie
was eddie and and the generation that
that he kind of brought in was the last
of the funny for snl
but he and he was very [ __ ] talented
he came from a time when you didn't
carry a a [ __ ] camera around in your
pocket
when that he came from a time when if
somebody when a camera was huge and when
they put it on you put a lot of stress
on you
okay he wasn't camera shy at all he
could improv and act back when film
costs a lot of money
where doing six six seconds of [ __ ]
costs [ __ ] thousands of dollars
it was a different time
uh he was ahead of his time
and um
man i [ __ ] i hope he comes out with i
hope the next eddie movie is beverly
hills cop four
i hope they don't call it four they
should have never called the [ __ ] three
or two but that's just the way it was
back then
we need another axo foley movie
because oh i would watch it on the back
of what he's done so far with the
dolomite movie and coming to america
part two
axel foley
a new axel foley movie is [ __ ] would
be awesome
especially when it had the right
soundtrack this is a great movie if you
guys haven't seen it then it's a much
it's a must watch this one and part two
yeah i mean as far as 80s movies go you
really got to see this one like like i
said 1984 was such an iconic year for
movies like i said not only this one but
ghostbusters and actually eddie murphy
was actually offered a part in
ghostbusters but he turned it down to do
this yeah good choice because he was i
mean he was friends with dan aykroyd
yeah so that's why so he did actually
get asked to do that but
i mean that would work too i think but
the thing about eddie murphy that's so
cool and not a lot of comedians have
this because some people are funny
but they can't be
relatable or likable or sympathetic but
eddie murphy is absolutely funny and
he's like naturally funny and he's also
somebody you can relate to he seems like
a regular guy and he seems like a
likable sympathetic character yeah which
like i said a lot of comedians can't
really do that no but to him like him he
just like has a natural
yeah he's so natural and he's uh he's
very american very american
yeah oh yeah yeah even though this was a
big hit like all around the world yeah
well that's why it was a big hit around
yeah he's just very american
yeah yeah i mean let's talk a little bit
because some people were talking about
the soundtrack for this
this is
this is one of the most 80s soundtrack
the thing about it is that pretty much
every
song on this soundtrack was also a
massive hit yeah uh you know the heat is
on that glen frye song all the pointer
sisters nasty girl uh neutron dance and
then there was yeah there was that that
was like axel f obviously like harold
faltermeyer that song i had forgotten
how what an ear worm that [ __ ] song
is because like when we watch the movie
i'm like it's still like stuck in my
head to this day
um you know you know it may be that was
like a couple days ago but
yeah this i mean this movie was like
not only the movie itself but like i
said the music from it was just like
this massive cultural phenomenon they
even had like mtv had videos for every
single one of the [ __ ] songs on this
i think patty uh wasn't patti labelle on
there see you on the soundtrack i want
to say probably yeah i remember pointer
sisters had a couple songs on there
and there were videos for like all the
songs and they would play them on mtv
like all the [ __ ] time and they had
you know clips from the movies and
everything some people also brought up
surge the best yeah surge surge that was
to make an appearance in every [ __ ]
if there is gonna be another which i'm
pretty sure there's gonna be another
[ __ ] axle folding movie surge has to
be his appearance bronson pinchot is
still alive right i mean he's got to be
god's gotta be gotta be i mean yeah if i
mean if you guys didn't know if you
didn't grow up in the 80s he was balky
on perfect strangers
sitcom
and so yeah he's only in this like two
scenes or something but it was like
absolutely huge
surge was surge was the uh the the gay
character that showed up and he's always
selling something in an art gallery and
and
and really axel
from detroit has nothing in common it
has nothing in common with this straight
white dude
from from
but
when you see the movie you're like he's
trying to [ __ ] have something in
common with this
artsy fartsy [ __ ]
gay white dude i really like i love the
interaction
it's a great scene every time he shows
the [ __ ] out of here
i know i cannot
[ __ ] and then in the second movie he
shows up as a [ __ ] arms dealer
selling selling high tech weaponry and
[ __ ] to axel there's all kinds of cool
[ __ ] that happens with [ __ ]
with [ __ ] surge
yeah i mean search is a really good
character it's kind of good now i want
to mention that one of the things that
kind of [ __ ] up
eddie murphy in the later part of his
[ __ ] career from the ninth from the
late 90s
is that uh the [ __ ] lgbt community
started to [ __ ] cr come down on him
about [ __ ] gay jokes
which the gay jokes were funny they were
not [ __ ]
kind of hateful they were just he poked
fun at everybody if you ask me
i think it was totally unjustified
and then it kind of came out that he was
running around that well there was a
couple things that came out about eddie
one he had some he had a foot fetish
and he had which that wasn't that would
might have been a big deal for normies
back then but [ __ ] i'm just like from
our scene where like he has a foot fit
so [ __ ] what
that's a pretty like tame fetish yeah
another thing came out is that he was
friends with a with a transgender
prostitute
and i'm like and again nowadays
and
me and jenny hang out in cubs where
there are [ __ ] [ __ ] prostitutes
[ __ ] everywhere some of them are
bodybuilders remember [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what's his name
yeah oh yeah yeah remember him two were
like would so what
so what you got a friend who's attracted
back then it was kind of back then it
was a big deal that was like a big deal
like what are you doing i mean that's
the mid 80s that was still what are you
worried about that was still like aids
panic and yeah all that kind of [ __ ]
there are gay jokes in this but i don't
i don't think they aged because i have
seen some movies from the 80s and 90s
where like the gay stereotypes like aged
very very badly and
they're kind of like hateful they seem
like a little bit hateful or they're
like making fun of it this one it's kind
of i don't think it's really making fun
of it it's just kind of like
i mean now i do love i still love you
it's more making fun of flaming
the the one scene where he goes in where
he wants to talk to you know the drug
dealer guy that he suspects being behind
the murder of his best friend because
that's what the movie yeah in case you
didn't know and to get in there
uh you know because the guy at the the
the maitre d he doesn't want to let him
in right so he like pretends yeah and he
just says you know what i can't remember
this so he's trying to he's trying to
become his herpes simplex i have herpes
simplex tan well he's saying
yeah yeah yeah so i i need to go talk to
him to get you right right before [ __ ]
starts falling off the man yeah
and and somebody got tested or something
like that it wasn't him he said it was
like a friend right yeah and you might
laugh at that scene and [ __ ] but let's
be honest a real life james bond would
be a chameleon he could become anything
and if and if he had to become gay to
get to the target that's exactly what he
would do and that's what axel does in
this movie that's that's what james bond
in real life would have to do he had he
had to become gay first well the thing
about it is where he's going this is
kind of yeah this is kind of interesting
to me because it just occurred to me
that the reason why i don't find that
particularly offensive is because
he's not making fun of gay people he's
making fun of people's discomfort of the
gay people exactly that's what he's
making fun of yeah that's the that's
where the joke is so he's not actually
no he had he had to become a gay to get
behind that to get around the maitre d
to get to get there that's that's
exactly what it was the discomfort
behind it tell him i have herpes same
thing stan
or maybe i should tell myself yeah and
he's like yeah why don't you do that
exactly yeah exactly it's [ __ ] it's a
brilliant scene
down says bronson pinchot does a lot of
audiobooks now he did horror store
actually oh that's cool that's grady
hendricks i have it right there um
now i kind of wonder i want to listen to
that although i have to say horror story
is one of those books that it's better
to like have the print version because
it looks like an ikea catalog and that's
kind of like part of the fun but it's
still a good story so you know
um john smith says eddie's aids jokes
and delirious did not age well yeah some
of the jokes in that didn't now i
haven't seen delirious or raw for a
really long time so
i don't know how humor humor in general
we've said it before does not age well
yeah which is why it's a lot more
miraculous when you see a movie like
this that is still absolutely just as
funny as it was back in the 80s right i
think ghostbusters is still funny too
yeah
eddie murphy of
in his 20s was a product of his time
everybody was it doesn't matter [ __ ]
who you were and
no it's just the way it was back then
he was a [ __ ] great performer and a
[ __ ] great a very creative dude and
uh you know a good american
a very good american entertainer um
[ __ ] i grew up with him and we
thought he was great and he and
watching his material
no it aged well he's good he's good yeah
everybody
this is still this is still absolutely
funny and i mean some most of the
funniest [ __ ]
i think originally they originally
conceived it as it was still going to be
fish out of water but it was just going
to be he was an la cop
and then going up to beverly hills but i
think it works better this way because
it's like way more efficient out of
water because la's yeah it's different
obviously but it's not different enough
yeah so
detroit beverly hills yeah that's like
polar opposites so i think that worked
out a lot better and i have to say too i
really really like the interaction
between his character and like the two
cops like ryan holding that rolls wood
rosewood and taggart there you go yeah
like they're like the way they where he
takes him to the strip club and [ __ ]
like that i mean just so so [ __ ]
funny because like taggart is like so
uptight yeah and that he's like the
uptight like by the book guy and then uh
tigers because every fairy kind of
[ __ ] oh hey you know do you know how
much red meat you have in your bowels
and then well no that's that's billy
right judge reinhold he's like the
younger rosewood is [ __ ]
judge reinhold is kind of like this sort
of he's not dumb necessarily but he's
just kind of well i don't know maybe he
is dumb he's like not really that bright
and he's kind of you know he's a cop in
beverly hills i'm sure they probably
don't have that much [ __ ] to do you know
what i mean so yeah he's
talking about how much red meat you have
in your bowels and stuff
like why are you eating that but yeah
that's like one of my favorite scenes
too is like when he orders them uh room
service and like has it had him take it
out to the car like while he's putting
the [ __ ] and judge ryan is all like
oh that's nice yeah is that shrimp yeah
it says it wasn't a friend it was a
trans hooker he picked up that's right
yeah and then she ended up being
murdered yeah but that was a friend of
his
that was a friend of his i just remember
yeah i remember that being like a big
scale of his like i'd have to like look
up i can't remember all the details but
yeah i do remember like my understanding
was that was a friend of his i mean
that's the way i i remembered it it was
just but i think it was just kind of
like a a person in the scene
that you know i mean they hung out
off and on and
if you're ever in a [ __ ] scene it's
going to have a good scene it's going to
have a bunch of people from a bunch of
different backgrounds and you're going
to be friends with them all it's usually
the scenes are [ __ ] centered around
nightclubs
and you're going to run into that you're
going to run into trans people and um
some of them are prostitutes because
a lot of you straight people don't
understand it
a [ __ ]
some trans people if they [ __ ] really
look
authentic and they look very convincing
they're worth a lot of money in the sex
trade
there are people that are willing to pay
a lot of money for that
they're very those are popular they're
very popular
so you're gonna see those it's just the
way it is
well and sometimes too depending on uh
what they look like
and other factors yeah sometimes too
they have a hard time
keeping a regular job because of people
being uncomfortable with that right so
sometimes they are kind of forced to do
that yeah money right uh which we knew
someone like that yeah that wasn't super
happy about right being a prostitute you
didn't really have a lot of other that's
where the money was coming from and it's
very expensive to for the the treatments
that they need they need [ __ ] hormone
therapies and they [ __ ] they want
surgeries and they want
so it costs a lot of money and they have
supporters
you know so
hearing that that [ __ ] came out about
eddie
at the time i was like that's some weird
[ __ ] but now i totally understand it i
understand that we know people like that
well in a way i'm glad that it's not
seen as weird anymore like i think if it
happened nowadays i think like people
would talk about it some people think
it's wrong well i you know i think
people would still talk about it but i
don't think it would be like this
massive [ __ ] deal like it was back in
the 80s right you know what i'm saying
because back then it was just like
like everyone flipped the [ __ ] out about
it yeah now everybody be like oh for
like five seconds right they'd be like
yeah well whatever right
trans people like that can um can be
very cool they're very interesting
[ __ ] you know i mean they're funny
you know they're very funny
um
one of the ones that me and jenny were
friends with
at the club
was
what was funny about her is that
she was built about like arnold
schwarzenegger she was the [ __ ]
bodybuilder that was trans
yeah and there was no hiding the fact
that she was
biologically male she was [ __ ] huge
it was all muscle she had like really
big muscular yeah imagine arnold
schwarzenegger with a wig
but for some reason then
i'mma want to miss jen the person in her
mind
she was convinced that she was female
but she was obviously a male bodybuilder
it was just
but we know other people that are
there are other ones that go to the club
that are
in the middle of making the
transformation there's about four other
ones we don't really know them that well
but they're around all the time the one
we knew i haven't seen her a long time
actually she had had top surgery yeah um
but like i said she was
like a like i said a lot of prostitution
and not super happy about it but you
know needed money and so she had been in
and out of jail
uh quite a bit
and so we haven't actually i haven't
seen her in a long time so i kind of
promise you
i kind of hope that she's okay probably
wherever she is because now that now
that i'm thinking about it i'm like
something but i hope nothing bad
happened to her because it's been a
while since i've seen i mean we haven't
been out right to eyebar for a long time
because she used to hang out there but
i i haven't seen her in probably in more
than a year
so i don't i know she was in and out of
jail like i said she was always getting
arrested like the cops knew who she was
because she was always getting busted
but
but when it comes to eddie eddie would
drive around the la area in the
hollywood area in his
ferrari i think it was a ferrari
and would pick up hotties from [ __ ]
all over town
from the scene
and um
we're talking about women
but every now and then
he would probably gonna stumble into
some trans people
but that doesn't
that doesn't mean he was [ __ ]
paying for anything it doesn't mean he's
having sex with anybody
it's kind of a dirty mind kind of
situation where you're reading into
things you don't know what happened
okay
and i'm not
it's really none of my business no
so
chances are
eddie being a cool dude just running
around picking up cool people from the
scene he didn't care who they were just
as long as they were cool that's
probably what it was
that's not gonna say what it was
uh slasher fred said this movie came out
the same year the most funniest
slapstick cop films did police academy i
you know what i feel like
i'd have to i've been have to rewatch
some of this i remember seeing the first
police academy and i think i saw which
one was citizens on patrol was that the
second one or the third one they made
like how many do they make 10
50 there was a lot but i remember seeing
the first couple and then being funny
but i don't know
you know i don't know how they would age
because it's been like a [ __ ] million
years since i've seen those and uh
grampher's then said about uh judge
reinhold in the most accurate
masturbation scene in all of cinema yeah
fast times at ridgemont oh yeah i forgot
about it
i mean yeah that was like that is like a
painful kind of [ __ ] team for a lot
of people to watch probably they're like
oh
uh granters also says debate and disgust
klinger on mash trans prostitute or
section eight faker
[Laughter]
griffin says ironically eddie got caught
with the trans process no
he wasn't caught with a trans process
what did he talk about
yeah yeah he wasn't caught having sex
with some trans prostitute well i think
they were just in the same car they were
in the same car yeah that doesn't mean
that means nothing
uh granthar says eddie's got more kids
than bob marley he did his part to
propagate this yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
hey and danny rowling said matt mccoy
was in police academy miami hey i just
did i just talked about the movie
absolutable which he was also in i
thought maybe i saw that maybe that's
why he was familiar well matt mccoy he
was familiar because he was the hand of
rocks at cradle that's where i knew i'm
from but i might be remembering him from
police academy of miami too but um yeah
so i can't believe like everybody here
has probably seen beverly hills cop
right i feel like everybody in the world
has seen beverly hills cop except maybe
if you're like really young you get a
pass then yeah but if you're young you
need to see it i mean yeah and and like
i said i have watched like some younger
reviewers that didn't see it back in the
old days and
like absolutely still think it's one of
the funniest movies ever so it's not our
imagination well see yeah that's why i'm
always kind of like interested to see
what they say yeah yeah although i will
say it's kind of weird it's like a
we've kind of talked about this before
it's like a really weird situation that
isn't anything like what we grew up with
because when we were growing up like you
didn't like the same [ __ ] as your
parents whatever they liked it that was
[ __ ] weird well now i'm not gonna say
that across the board because my dad was
into like some good music that i liked
also um you know he was like in the
beatles and the doors and stuff and i
like that but um and i even liked that
when i was younger
so it's not you know absolutely like
applies across the board but
yeah it was seen as strange if you were
into the same [ __ ] that your parents
were into
um but now that doesn't really seem all
that weird because now there's like
[ __ ] 20 year olds on tick tock that
are super super into the 80s like
they're all into like 80s music and 80s
fashion there's like a whole subset of
like people on there and that is [ __ ]
crazy to me there is some cool [ __ ]
about the 80s there's a lot of cool 80s
in this movie but one of the things that
was in this movie that was 80s that was
not cool was [ __ ] what jenny jenny's
[ __ ] outfit like in this in about
this not me not there
[Laughter]
jenny's outfit about halfway through it
was this baggy gray looking thing and
i'm just like how the hell could you put
a woman into some [ __ ] like that what
was that thing man yeah although i have
to say just i know that's the character
was named jenny i was also named jenny
but i don't even know what the [ __ ] i
was wearing in 1984 i'm sure it didn't
look any better than that that's for
sure because i was only 12. imagine if a
member's only jacket was a jacket and a
pants
yeah it was like
terrible god gathered legs yeah and it's
like well that's one thing there's a lot
of cool [ __ ] about the 80s and i liked a
lot of the kind of
some of the fashion in the 80s but a lot
of the fashion in the 80s was awful
especially like for women yeah like what
was with the [ __ ] shoulder pads and
those big high
[ __ ] high-ass like
like aerobic looking like underwear god
damn that looked awful yeah but
like all that aerobics gear that
everybody was wearing is like regular
clothes like in leg warmers and [ __ ] and
i had leg warmers i'm not gonna lie you
know so
i wormed when i was roller skating but
you know what i mean but
yeah that outfit was really terrible god
so what else about this movie how much
you got uh there in terms of [ __ ]
data not you know nothing really i'm
just like i'm kind of like talking about
it and like i said most people have seen
it and
have like kind of uh talked about it
yeah and we talked about the whole like
weird cobra situation yeah which all
right my take on the movie
as far as 80s movie goes within the
context of this movie it's a 10 out of
10.
you got to see this movie
if you haven't seen it you have to see
it yeah i mean it's a required viewing
and i remembered [ __ ] part two being
even better but we're gonna watch that
tonight
we'll see yeah so we'll talk about part
two we'll talk about it and then we'll
because you have all three of them right
i have all three of them so we'll yeah
we'll watch part two tonight and talk
about that tomorrow and then we'll watch
part three we can do that and then then
i want to see golden child i mean we can
do the whole
golden job yeah we watched it but we
haven't i don't think we've done a
review on it yeah or dude we're going to
do we can do the whole beverly hills cop
trilogy and then we can do pokemon child
next week i guess okay so we'll see how
that goes but yeah i'm kind of like look
i don't think i ever saw the third one
the other one's not
i might be wrong i mean when i watch it
i may be like oh yeah maybe i just i i
don't remember it being bad per se just
not as good as the other two you kind of
slightly like
kind of like it was thrown together
we'll see we'll see been a while since
i've seen it
uh yeah no need for me too says the
opening and pacing is almost 100 no
spots drag for me yeah that's yeah this
is really like a very very well paced
like right action there's always
something action oriented or something
funny going on
so it is never boring it is as good as
the other movies from this year say like
[ __ ] um
ghostbusters it is that it is as good as
ghostbusters yeah it's just a different
kind of movie it's a it's a police
adventure it actually made more money
than ghostbusters i think ghostbusters
was like second okay um right after it
but
i remember seeing ghostbusters in the
theater i don't think i saw this in the
theater i think i saw this on cable like
a year or two later i did see
ghostbusters in the theater but um yeah
i mean like i said 1984 man and somebody
brought up earlier like i forgot
nightmare on elm street the first one
came out in 1984 too holy crap yeah that
was like a [ __ ] embarrassment of
riches that year i just can't believe
that they attacked eddie murphy for
having a foot fetish i like cute feet
too feet are ugly
if
if a chicken the average foot is [ __ ]
ugly if if somebody's got cute feet
though
yeah you get a cute feet
yeah i don't understand because it is
rare to see this is very rare to see qfe
i mean my feet are just
they're good they're good they're
they're they're
not cute not ugly
i don't have a thing where i'm pursuing
cute feet but i [ __ ] love shoes but
he appreciates yeah he's
i got a shoe fetish not so much foot
fish yeah
now it's not so bad that i just need
just the shoe i don't want the woman
they got these that are that bad dudes
that are so bad they're [ __ ] women i
just want to skip the shoe
she doesn't talk back yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know they got some dudes
they're just so [ __ ] bad into it that
they just want the shoe yeah and i can't
really like the object yeah yeah i can't
understand it that is kind of weird well
no it's all on a spectrum so you can
kind of see that's the very extreme end
of the spectrum where they don't
[Laughter]
well like i said if it came out somebody
like well look man quentin tarantino's
made a [ __ ] career out of having a
foot fetish yeah and everybody makes
jokes about it but nobody's gonna like
you know his [ __ ] is a little weird
though he's in defeat that i'm not into
he kind of yeah he likes like um they're
like longer feet yes
no little short little [ __ ] baby feet
i can understand that
little baby feet
i can understand that but it's this way
the chinese would say the chinese like
the foot wrapping little foot binding
where there's like major major feet all
like deformed yeah right right so you
can fit him in those like
yeah i can't but no that's [ __ ] up
yeah i've seen some of those actual like
foot binding shoes like in museums and
stuff and it's like i can't even imagine
it was too yeah don't if you haven't
seen him like don't google like how that
what that did your feet because it's
like really great yeah so then you said
no need from you said the opening and
the pacing is 100 that's right yeah
really the movie
the movie is kind of 100
the ending of the movie
ends in a big shootout
you can tell that the shootout is more
like wrapping it up
there is a bunch of gun mythology in it
let me get into the guns before we ship
before we start this
some of y'all are gonna gunna files i'm
a [ __ ] i love [ __ ] guns
it has some aspects to this movie axel's
foley is [ __ ]
through through the movie he's carrying
the browning high power
they came out in 1935 it's a very
classic single action automatic
[ __ ] dual column nine millimeter
pistol it was retro even in the day that
this movie came out but a good choice
better than the smith and wesson double
action autos double action autos that
were around
at that time or d a's sa autos which
they showed some of those in the flick
uh [ __ ] the browning high power was
the elegant solution and to me when i
see a [ __ ] civilian
browning high power i think axel foley
uh
now his
shooting skills [ __ ] up in the movie
but i'm not gonna [ __ ] talk much
about that his tactical shit's [ __ ] up
uh in a lot of the [ __ ] things where
he's firing at the enemy his eyes are
closed so he's not staring over the top
of the slide so you know eddie is not a
real shooter
but it's okay it's just a [ __ ] movie
it's a comedy it's just the [ __ ] yeah
uh another thing that happens in him
that's not
not [ __ ] all that is that the bad guy
victor maitland shoots eddie broadside
in the shoulder broadside should have
been this way because he was turned
sideways shoots him bra
signing the shoulder with a [ __ ] four
inch or three and a half inch but three
inch
41 magnum or 44 magnum
smith wesson revolver
eddie's narrow ass
that [ __ ] that bullet would have went
through three eddies sideways
and it just goes into his second
shoulder but he shrugs it off now that's
that never would have happened not with
that that was what he got but like i
said you can't just never watch the
movie because yeah pretty much every
action movie in the 80s like somebody
gets shot
and in real life they'd have been like
in agony and they're just picked up well
i gotta shake it off yeah
he got shot a long way through the
shoulder with a 44 or 41 magma would
have gone through straight through three
eddie murphy's
even if it was a hollow point
and but he's like oh i'm okay i'm good
nah
it'll blow that hitting bone that bone
would have fragmented like a bomb yeah
and then that bullet would have [ __ ]
gone right through that rib cage and out
through the other arm and through three
other [ __ ] eddie murphys that would
have killed him better than [ __ ]
uh but it's just a movie that's just a
movie
i mean you know if you like the movie
you'll forgive a lot and like i said
they did that a lot in the 80s like
people well they still do it nowadays
like somebody in a movie gets horribly
injured not just a shot like any kind of
like horrible injury and they're still
hey can you be yeah i'm fine i'm fine
no a crocodile like bit my leg off but
i'm i'm good oh yeah all right
i'll be all right yeah i'll be all right
oh one more fact that i once i really
wanted to bring this up because this is
crazy to me remember how i said that
martin scorsese was the first director
that they wanted for this
you know who another director they asked
to do this was david cronenberg
good david
cronenberg
directing beverly hills cop uh he would
have gotten a wrong and the tone would
not have been that's what i'm saying
that would have been really really weird
like i said if i don't know like i don't
really feel like has he ever done
anything like funny
i don't think so like he doesn't really
do a lot of body horror anymore like he
usually does kind of like crime
thrillers nowadays um but or that type
of thing
but
in the 80s man
that would have been super bizarre all
right now my boy graham jumps in it says
detroit pd would have issued him a smith
and wesson model 66 with a six inch
barrel probably right
66 i believe was a 357 magnum i think i
had a uh
uh what was that the uh
i had a [ __ ] smith wesson uh 586 with
a six inch barrel it was 357 magnum i
think the 66 was 3-7 too
um now uh grantharis was
raptors he was michigan police but you
you weren't were you pd were you um
detroit police department i don't
remember which which uh agency you
worked for
but uh yeah did he get although he was a
detective
so maybe a detective would have been
able to purchase his own firearm i i
don't i don't know yeah i'm not sure how
i'm not sure how it would have worked
back then right a [ __ ] a b cop
patrolman probably would have had to
carry an issue weapon but i think a
[ __ ] detective probably would never
buy his own
that's what he said
and a um
a browning high power
would have been a retro choice but kind
of rational in uh 84. it was the 84 84
yeah that would have been older because
that came out in 1935
uh but
you know firearms development
pre-computers
uh didn't move along with all that
quickly
autocad had a lot to do with the
development of [ __ ]
firearms i could see that oh yeah it
changed [ __ ] a lot
and the uh the browning high power
1935 probably high power was [ __ ]
relevant way into the 80s
uh now smith and wesson was coming out
with some double action single action
auto
nine millimeter and 40 smith wesson
stuff that was kind of nice but they
were kind of bulky and
unproven
uh the broading high power was slim and
kind of refined single action auto
it had a really good grip angle that
[ __ ] was one of the best grip angles
back of the day you just grab it you go
oh this feels [ __ ] great it was a
natural pointer
kind of like a 1911 but
a little tighter up around the top of
the [ __ ] backstrap just
your gun people know exactly what i'm
talking about
um
my [ __ ] walter p99s
uh walter ppqs
they got a new version of [ __ ] the
ppq that just come out they kind of have
that same
feeling around the grip
it's kind of narrower at the top
narrower than than say a glock
and there's just something nice about
the way that they point
um
let's see what it's a grammy yeah
gramsci said i was a fed who worked in
detroit my official title was special
agent okay okay
now you went by mr or sir okay now now
could
could you purchase could you purchase
your own firearm though or did you have
to carry something that was issued
that's what i want to know
because could could foley have been able
to purchase his own brownie high power
and carry it as a detective
well the thing about it is that
technically when he went to beverly
hills he was technically on vacation
yeah but they showed his firearm back in
[ __ ] that's true back in detroit and
it was that browning high power okay
when his friend broke into his apartment
and he pulled it yeah that's his
[ __ ] i forgot his [ __ ] [ __ ]
imt in the individual movement tactics
the [ __ ]
fourth throw down says i guess this is
in reference to me saying about david
cronenberg like directing this movie
fourth throw down says yeah axel foley
discovers that the bad guy is the
incredible melting man right
grabner says no he would not be able to
buy his own
firearm okay well there you go all right
now we know now we know
but it would have been a model 66 smith
and wesson is what grandfather is saying
well i guess which is a revolver it's a
movie right so okay i don't want to be
one of those people that's like because
i know that there's whole youtube
channels probably right of people being
like well this is not correct
but it's like you know have have a fun
time just watch the movie and don't
think about it
guys want to know about the equipment
and the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what it is
that you know we want to know we don't
it doesn't it's not it's like it's funny
not to take us away out of the movie we
just want to know what would it really
be like i kind of feel like it does
though because a lot of times like we'll
be watching a movie and he'll get like
all wrapped up in that kind of stuff and
then he's like wait what's happening
because he's like oh
who's this now
was saying you could only in detroit you
could have only carried what was issued
and it would have been a smith wesson 66
that's what he's in those days okay
there you go okay i mean to me i was
just like he has a gun it's fine yeah
let's get on with the story yeah
[Laughter]
let's get out of the store let's see
what's going on but yeah um you know i
get it i get it yeah i'm just saying i'm
just i'm just [ __ ] with the harleys
are out there riding around yeah it's
sunday everybody but still graham
the [ __ ] browning high power was a
[ __ ] nice choice for [ __ ] 84.85
that would have been a great choice
yeah yeah all righty so man we went on
almost an hour yeah um so we're going to
watch beverly hills cop 2
this evening and we will be back
tomorrow
talking about that so hopefully you can
join us for that because i haven't seen
that in a long time i forgot everything
about that jason's asking is detroit a
really rough city i'm laughing yes
detroit was the [ __ ] apocalypse
especially back in the 80s and the 90s
80s 70s 80s 90s i mean i feel like it's
better now because a lot of people left
but you know what i mean yes nowhere
near as dangerous as it was because
they're all dead or gone because they're
it's mostly yeah it's gone now they tore
a lot of it down but back in the day it
was like [ __ ] beirut
it was [ __ ] bad
yeah i loved it though as a kid
i loved it
yeah because you lived there in what the
90s yeah before i went to the service
yeah that's where i bought my first
pistol and i bought it from a crackhead
it was a cz-75
[Laughter]
yeah it was a tampa league cz75 thanks
crackhead yeah
yeah you got crack you got it it didn't
work though but i fixed it
yeah yeah
oh well
all right so we'll be back tomorrow
talking about beverly hills cop2
so we'll see you guys then thanks for